hey what's happening everybody thanks
for tuning in to another episode of let
to be talked this is what is today man
it's Monday what's the day never know
the date the 21st which is hilarious
because of this episode me saying I
don't know the date brought to you by
earth quaker devices my favorite people
my favorite sponsor been sponsoring the
podcast for over two years looks like a
lot of you guys are starting to buy some
stomp boxes from a badass they are the
best handmade from akron ohio check em
out get one of their petals get in
acapulco gold you want to sound stony
get in acapulco go a pedal what's up
buds welcome to the new acapulco gold
pedal the acapulco gold is a dirt simple
power amp distortion cranked up this
pedal goes to 11 yeah daddies guys got
great pedal so you're the names acapulco
gold avalanche run dunes grey channel
tentacle these guys are fantastic you
play guitar keyboards jazz music metal
music funk soul country doesn't matter
everybody uses a foot pedal a stomp box
making an Earthquaker device device
device device device find them on
earthquaker devices calm or follow them
on Twitter and Instagram rock and roll
alright let's go to the episode today
that was a little bit of at the drive-in
that you just heard right there during
the front of this show and oh man
they're back together and this week
they're going to be playing in town i'll
be hosting the show they're doing the
fonda on wednesday the 23rd they're also
out in pomona i believe on the
twenty-second hit their website at the
driving calm and I mean this is [ __ ]
great I didn't see him on that last
reunion run arm what was that a few
years ago they played Coachella a lot of
a lot of dates they played that summer
but as Cedric was talking there was some
things going on in the band and it
probably wasn't as good as it could have
been this time it's going to be face
melting face-melting so I can't wait man
this band is so [ __ ] good I've said
it over and over and over if you've ever
seen him play one arm scissors at the on
David Letterman who [ __ ] insane insane
man the energy is ridiculous the songs
are amazing and it is just straight in
your face [ __ ] danger so check them
out they're going out on tour all over
hit their website make sure you see them
i'll be at the fonda on wednesday and
i'll tell you guys about it on thursday
and it looks like i might finally get to
interview omar at the at the gig so
fingers crossed a couple things going on
this week before i get into the episode
which by the way the episode is going to
be great today it's another another
series another another episode in the
series of handmade although Kevin and I
didn't make watches we love them and
they are handmade the ones we love and
we discuss Rolexes tutor
an arai patek philippe all the watches
that came out this weekend at baselworld
2016 if you don't know anything about
watches it's still going to be
interesting because it's basically a
passion episode Kevin and I love watches
and whatever you love maybe your friends
don't understand it like what do you
mean you collect Pez dispensers yeah
yeah I Pez dispensers you tell them you
know whatever you collect and you love
it's a passion and kevin and i have a
fierce passion for watches especially
Rolexes and tutor and we wanted to
dedicate an episode to it and give you a
little bit of an insight if you don't
know anything about watches so you're
going to enjoy this Kevin Christie great
friend of mine amazing comedian great
painter great artist and just great
human before i get into that though i
just want to say my current obsession is
pink floyd's record metal medd le not m
et al not metal but metal and I just
went down a rabbit hole one night was
watching some david gilmour stuff
because i'm going to see him this week
at the Hollywood Bowl and I was looking
at a set list and I realized holy [ __ ]
he's going to be playing stuff off metal
I can't [ __ ] wait and irie fired it
up went and got a nice nice sweet copy
of metal on vinyl threw it on and been
playing it all [ __ ] week especially
side to which is just one song echoes
and it is insane so if you don't own
Pink Floyd's metal I recommend you get
this thing right away it is so smoking
we're this thing come out I can't even
remember let me see if i could find it
such a great
[ __ ] record um [ __ ] I can't find it
hold on let me look it up because I
don't want to [ __ ] drop the ball on
this anyway Pink Floyd man I just been
I've been [ __ ] hooked on them and
grateful dead for about a year now came
out in 71 on Halloween what a [ __ ]
great record to come out on Halloween
I've really just been going crazy over
just psychedelic music lately and it's
funny how relaxing it is psychedelic
music relaxing like I'll be sitting
around the house I'll just put it on
I'll be like [ __ ] amazing and if you
really want to [ __ ] lose your mind
put on pink floyd echoes on youtube the
live one at a what is that the palm pili
or whatever what's that place called
here it is and 72 they went out there
and played in one of these old old like
bullfighting looking arenas and they
played with no one no one no one in the
stadium I'm looking at the video right
now two million seven hundred fifty-four
thousand views insane anyway they played
out there in the middle of the day and
just did this [ __ ] incredible
psychedelic concert psychedelic concert
psychedelic music but no psychedelic
lights or anything just proving that
pink floyd can crush it just as as
musicians they don't they don't need all
that other [ __ ] it's just extra cool i'm
babbling on right now just because i'm
so like just so obsessed with this
record in the last week just can't get
enough of it great great record opens
with one of these days a pillow of a
pillow of winds fearless sentra pay it's
just [ __ ] smoking the album cover art
school anyway get it that's my obsession
right now and also I'm back on the bike
have you seen my Instagram I'm outride
and again feels good and thanks for all
your support people keep telling your
friends about the podcast and what else
believe the reviews what are you doing
leave a review we're trying to get to a
thousand reviews I mean the amount of
listeners I have in the amount of
reviews i got like five hundred and
sixty or something but let's try to make
that thing go to a thousand it's [ __ ]
it it helps the podcast big time and
it's fun if you want to donate to the
podcast go to patreon.com/scishow I am
I'll be headlining the irvine improv
April 13th headlining at La Jolla Comedy
Store April 22nd 23rd and also
headlining in denver at the Comedy Works
jun 28th through july second those are
some of the upcoming Road dates can't
wait to see you guys anyway let's get to
the episode right here time to light the
candles Kevin Christie let's do it all
right here we are another episode of
that to be taught and this is a another
installment of my handmade series I've
made nothing by hand and neither has my
guest that i know of he is an incredible
drawer a great friend and an artist and
a comedian and the angel that picked me
up on the highway you remember that
episode 22 hey Suze bro you're Dean's
angel yeah um but are my thing was today
I want to explain a couple things I'm an
absolute watch fanatic yeah so is Kevin
Christie for sure and we've talked about
it many times it's how we we bonded at
the atomic aim friends for the first
time yeah because at the car
restore he you gotta find something that
that gets you yeah everyone's a comic so
that's not that's nothing to connect on
yeah and not only that but when you're a
total stranger at the store you know you
ooh concert shirt oh cool vans yeah a
watch yeah now I want to explain
something because a lot of times when I
tweet or Instagram watch photos people
like [ __ ] at five grand 10 grand a
hundred grand to integrand for watch
you're out of your mind but what people
don't understand is and mostly my love
is of rolex and same with kevin if you
smoke cigarettes every day which i guess
i used to in like 96 you don't smoke for
one year and you've got a Rolex yeah and
I don't like I don't drink that like me
freaking too it costs the whole [ __ ]
Forge way more than cigarettes yes these
watches aren't that much money I think
growing up especially for me you always
heard Rolex well that guy's rich yeah
and what people don't understand is you
can get right in at two grand yeah I
mean most of the role I've never bought
a really expensive Rolex and also I
realized before i was before i bought
one i was wasting money on watches that
were maybe cheaper that I would that I
didn't like as much that's how you end
up buying a lot of stuff that you don't
end up keeping whereas you get a Rolex
and you're pretty much satisfied with it
like I every time I've had one you don't
have one now because he knows why i sold
it for me yes i'm sold all your watch
yeah steen sells watches really fast so
he sells all my watches my cell and my
dog my dog needed tons of medical
attention which now his nickname is
Rolex cuz that's how much it cost yes
that's what we should call him for now I
do it no I his name's cub but I go
c'mere Rolex hey Submariner yeah he cost
as much is a brand new gmt to now so
anyway if watches aren't your thing and
you think people are crazy just look
around your house at whatever you
collect and and somebody probably thinks
you're crazy like you know you're
uh your star trac dolls your precious
moments sculptures yeah your those paint
by numbers I love paint-by-numbers
painting I [ __ ] love paint by numbers
dude they're so good but my dad
collected those lladro sculptures yeah
they're vine copious well you got an
incredible bit too about the disney
vault oh yeah yeah yeah yeah people who
collect those disney they have those
disney sculptures that are like limited
edition of only five thousand yeah like
look if you like it rad if you think
it's gonna appreciate you're high I
always laugh at the term Toyota limited
yeah like what are you [ __ ] talking
about do you know what limited means
limited means usually to me and I was
talking to somebody recently good man
how did you sell your your super is so
fast you know I always get stuff that's
crazy rare so when I get in trouble I
can turn it real quick in trouble
meaning money-wise like oh no rent this
month yeah boom this is out of here so
limited Toyota and even with Rolex
there's no there's millions of Rolexes
out there yeah there's a sell more
watches and probably anybody Omega sells
a ton of watches tag does too but Rolex
cells tons and tons and tons of watches
yeah yeah and uh so my point is if you
want to get into a Rolex there's two
ways to do it and we're cheaply and one
would be the one that you were quite a
bit was the date just yeah I love an old
datejust it's a smaller model if you
want a big watch it's not for you but
like it fit i have a small risks with
fit my wrist really well and you can
find those use from the 60s and 70s and
early 80s for between two and three
thousand dollars yep and the great thing
about them is they're they're durable
you can they're steel so you can bump
into stuff and they keep super good time
yeah as a self-winding yeah self-winding
you just have to wear it and I think
they look really rad like you know Paul
Newman war one and color of money like
it's such a good 70s like watch
it's really i'm a big fan i'll probably
get another one yeah i mean and uh and
and still people are probably going like
23 grand per watch [ __ ] that but the
reason i'm calling this a handmade
syriza's these watches man if you look
what goes into making a time mechanism
so do you what else is 50 years old and
still works yeah that's the thing though
like i've owned most of day chess i
voted from own were from the 60s so
that's a 50 year old watch that still
runs perfectly like keeps perfect time
it's crazy that and whenever that was
made yeah we think people like you know
in the future they won't even take you
know they won't even count time yeah
could you imagine like could you imagine
if we changed actual time styles not
ever and all sudden all the watches were
just useless because they won't they
don't do time well there used to be two
kinds of time there was um sunlight time
and then there was mechanical time and
they were different well there was the i
read a book on the history of time and
there was the time that this that was
literally followed by the Sun and then
there was mechanical time there was a
town where like the clock the the like
people didn't carry why sundown no no it
was like actual clock the mechanical
clock was like there was a few times a
year and it was 15 minutes different
well then what most people thought of as
the time because farmers keep like
actual like sun and moon time because
that's what time is to them it's you
know you work at you work at sunup
sundown but like mechanical time was
like a little faster wow that is so
crazy and it's perfect that we're doing
this episode right when we just push the
clock forward a stupid time where you
know was just so [ __ ] dumb everyone's
still exhausted yeah right now the the
point of today's episode is every year
these if you're a watch nerd like we are
there's a weekend when they debut the
new watches now these companies Rolex
Omega pad tech patek philippe when all
these guys keep this [ __ ] so [ __ ]
super secret
super secret it's like harley-davidson
you never know what's going to come out
yeah yeah it's you know proprietary
technology they want to like because
that way they can maintain that they're
releasing something no one else has and
it's but it's really secretive and
especially when it comes to like rolex
and tutor they're releasing stuff that's
like people have been like anticipating
subtle changes in the models for a long
time and hoping new things come out so
it's always kind of a big nerdy watch
time lots of dudes on the internet will
speculate on what's coming out and then
do these like nerdy Photoshop versions
of new watches which is cool oh yeah it
makes us crazy oh yeah because like will
see a model and a guy will be incredible
with Photoshop and yeah change stuff on
and you'll be like oh man I hope that
comes out what did you send me that you
thought we ought master stainless oh
yeah with the monochrome yak bezel it
looked super real and I was like I think
that's fake got it looks super real and
it looked super [ __ ] boner yeah Oh
nourishes not into the rubber strap but
no now so once a year they have this
thing it's called baselworld yeah it's a
new zealand and switzerland and all the
companies get there and they release
their watches and so every year usually
Rolex is is a lot like harley-davidson
to me where they're really stuck in the
old world where they're like this is our
design yeah we don't go off the map and
this is what we like and every year
people get totally bummed because I
follow the rock the watch rolex form
yeah and they'll be like [ __ ] I can't
believe they didn't do nothing yes here
roller does one of the secrets to
Rolexes success and I believe what
tutors following now is they make very
few changes and when they do change
things it's very subtle yeah so that the
in that part of it that is smart
branding because then when you see
someone you see a Rolex you know what it
is you're like that's a Rolex I know
what a Rolex looks like that's a tutor I
know what a tutor looks like yeah and I
think that is part of the secret to
their success but for people that follow
the brand super hard you're hoping for
like something new and crazy but it just
they do it very slowly yeah so a lot of
people are
people yeah a lot of people want like a
change to come already because it you
know a lot of the models and one we're
probably going to talk about a lot like
the Daytona has stayed the same the
steel stainless steel Daytona has stayed
the same for since nine the 90s yeah
absolutely late 90s late 80s Early 90s
when that steel Daytona I think changed
over and it's been it's looked basically
like that for so now you're going on
close to over 20 years yeah and the
point of the point that I think I want
to make here is that a lot of people
want the changes because the vintage
ones have become so much money yeah
specific models that people don't want
to wear those or they can't afford them
being won the Daytona Paul Newman
Daytona which can go for up to like a
million dollars and now they're up in
the high hundreds of thousands depending
on box and papers and condition and [ __ ]
so it's become a watch that's basically
out of almost everyone's reach right so
what a lot of companies have done uh-oh
megha tutor Rolex a lot of companies at
IWC even they've been making models that
are a little more inspired by the
vintage look in their past because they
are so much more affordable to buy and
you my room with that you can worry
about you know like ruining this piece
of art you actually because the way
these Rolexes aged a patina and they be
eat one it's totally [ __ ] different
man yeah like I saw watch recently that
was only 10 years old but a surfer
warrant every day surfing in Malibu and
everything on it was totally faded and
that was incredible yeah I was like wow
look at the fate of patina on this thing
yeah it's cool so Rolex um this is the
first year really i think in a long long
time that we kind of lost our mind i got
up on wednesday morning i was woken i
was woken up by text messages said 7am
yeah listen I was like this isn't what
is who's texting me at 7am and in 18
yeah cuz it was you know 7pm in
Switzerland right
so the the basil releases it happen and
I was just getting texted I was being
texted pictures of watches like I was
awake and said hey text me pictures well
you're the only one I could nerd out
with on it you know the meaning like and
and I I just couldn't believe what I saw
yeah yeah well this is the as far as new
releases go for rolex this is probably
the best year since the milgauss or that
when the new gmt came out that's right i
mean when the new subs came out it was
pretty cool but they weren't so
mind-blowing your talk it was a
different bezel in the case was wider
yeah but it wasn't like crazy but when
the milgauss came out that was crazy
deal when the gmt to see came out that
was a big deal but this was by far the
most releases that were different models
size wise and design wise that we've
seen in a long time right because
usually they'll do one watch and then
everything else will stay the same yeah
like the yacht-master too yea the deep
sea was their venture into a big watch
ya um a little cost oh yeah total
failure the milgauss which is like what
the [ __ ] lightning bolt arm I call it
the ac/dc rocker mom people call it the
Rasta yeah the Bob Marley it's called
sometimes yeah awesome and then before
that would be like this is as radical as
they'd get before a sub with a green
bezel yeah yeah they changed the bezel
color and that was about it yeah now
most people know Rolex by the most
famous one which would be the Submariner
worn by James Bond probably the most
famous watch ever absolutely louis ck a
very famous for wearing it Robert
Redford and All the President's Men gave
McQueen Steve McQueen who else uh I mean
everyone it's moka Guevara yeah really
yeah Wow and what's the what's the dude
that ran Cuba forever him ran what Cuba
oh yeah Fidel Fidel Castro wore a Rolex
lots of people who was the gangster that
will cost me loves a gmt haha
p i love to GN o magnum p.i wore the gmt
yeah and then Paul Newman Nero where's
the sub every let their just a very
common DiCaprio where's us up sometime
so does Brad Pitt now let me explain to
you guys you can get into a sub for five
grand yeah at this point [ __ ] nine you
can get a 90 submariner between the
years of 95 and two thousand four five
thousand bucks I see I saw one the other
day for 4,700 yep and that wats old new
for about 3 grand you know in the 90s
yeah what it is would it allow maybe
about four well I got one in 96 or
something it was like 30 too hot okay
[ __ ] yeah I could do now also a very
popular watch is the Explorer one yes
which was watch worn to Mount Everest it
was the further the Explorers war to
Everest that one had a white waffle dial
and if you have that desert impossible
to find yeah but the next best thing to
that one is the am at dial 1016 unbeli
it's a great-looking watch incredibly
classic looking super simple dial just
black and white and has three six nine
and then a triangle marker and it's
thirty six millimeters and oyster
bracelet and the thing is perfect and
now we went through the phase of big
watches panra eyes and all those a
Huebel who blow and all that [ __ ] was
giant watches and but in the 90s 36 was
standard men's size a men's watch didn't
get above much above thirty six
millimeters unless it was a dive watch
right there are really big omegas in the
70s but they were flight watches and
dive watches the flightmaster was very
big size wise Monaco yeah the Monaco
yeah the heuer monaco was pretty big but
those for a watch to be large it was
considered sport watch it was usually a
chronograph but but before that even
chronographs were thirty six millimeters
I mean the Newman Daytona is thirty six
millimeters 27 the milgauss was 37 back
then the original one and to put it into
perspective for you guys 36 is probably
what every grandfather and your dad ever
war the panerai kind of came back into
business and their watches are forty
eight millimeter which is giant they're
huge and and that was really hot for a
while because of Stallone and all these
guys fortunately I go there where they
originally designed for the italian
military to be in it the big dial they
were big on purpose because you needed a
big dial that glowed in the dark to see
inside a dark submarine yep so that's
why they were so big they're originally
made with Rolex movements and those are
worth the fortune they're worth a crazy
JJ Abrams has yeah but nobody wears them
anymore because they're big and dobby
looking now yeah yeah I had one and it
was [ __ ] it never fit under my
motorcycle jacket yeah i mean i have
i've had a couple and i have the wrist
of a sickly of a sickly lady and it
looked really stupid on me but i love
the way i just like the shape of the
case oh no oh the thing with panerai as
they're spectacular yeah glow is
unbelievable easy to read the shape is
cool that the little thing that covers
the the crown is cool and a latch yeah
it's just they're great-looking they're
just too big for my wrist yeah matter of
fact when I would wear one on stage I
could see people staring at it yeah it's
distracting it is it is it's a giant
watch yeah so anyway let's get back into
Rolex oh they release their stuff and
the all-time some of the all-time
biggest Rolex collectors collect the
Paul Newman Daytona yeah and it's um
it's there's a famous one which would be
called the Panda yeah it's a it's a
chrono watch and has three dials yes the
three little circles on it and it has a
black there's two ver I think there's
two versions one of the black bezel one
with a metal bezel right and it's got
this kind of white dial some of the
doubt panda dials have a red sub tract
around it yeah it's called a tricolor
dial but they're legendary and the funny
thing is this they were a dog when they
came out yeah there were total failure
no one no one liked him but Paul Newman
war one I didn't believe I it was first
captured on the cover of an Italian
racing magazine right and then it became
the Newman Daytona and people started
kind of collecting him because of that
I'm actually called him that yeah they
call him Newman de Paul Newman they
don't even call him date ailments yes so
and they just became incredibly
collectible over time have become
probably the most the two most
sought-after Rolexes I think are
probably a Newman Daytona and big crown
a big crown submariner because of James
Bond yep it's a forget what numbers like
if maybe a 50 50 saw one yesterday it
was 350 thousand dollars yeah I couldn't
live I have a tropical dial yeah like a
burnt butterscotch brown dial it faded
that much and those are like the head
those are the watches of like hedge fund
manager yeah one sold at christie's in
2012 for 680,000 yeah razy yeah it's
crazy so they're not wearable you can't
like you can't really buy one and the
risk and buying one that's wrong or fake
is so [ __ ] high so high now my my my
thing I always say is Harley Davidson
and rolex are a lot the same because
they made some of the most classic
[ __ ] [ __ ] and year after year after
year I'm like why don't they just mind
their history yeah iCarly put out a
modern-day knucklehead they could do it
you have this bike that's exact to a
1936 knuckle which is considered the
most iconic Harley of all time right
with modern-day you know stuff ABS when
you look at the blank it looks like a
vintage bike better see hell yeah and
it's all their own [ __ ] so they go we're
not copying nothin if we invented this
[ __ ] I wonder what I would the problem
Rolexes are so secretive yeah about
their design process and why they do
things i would i would be very curious
to hear why their rationale behind that
I mean it makes sense did I look we have
this great history but we also want to
be making advances because we don't want
people to be only caring about our old
watches right well that's what happened
with Harley they they never really tried
to go for the younger crowd yeah and
also never passed up by people who took
serious chances ducati and BMW in design
fine and um like state-of-the-art [ __ ]
like ABS brakes right traction control
and all that [ __ ] and not now Harley's
like oh [ __ ] because all their people
are dying and yeah people aren't like
they're kind of an old dude by company a
little bit and it's a lot how Rolexes
looked at oh yeah a little bit because
they just always have the sub that
you're just the Daytona you know yeah so
yeah that's that's I think what some
people I mean me especially old Rolex
collectors love super classic look so
that's why we always want rolex keeps
things super similar and bring back tiny
things like red type because also you
see what other companies do like the
Omega releases a basil word jive as L oh
yeah they were disco dude they were just
wacky ass colors and last year they were
the winners yell out he was creepy yeah
and the other without while the one I
loved Whiteside the moon yeah [ __ ]
unbelievable watches last year they
absolutely squished everyone but that's
what was omegas undoing in the 70s as
they went super drive these weird quartz
watches with weird designs like the if
you want to see a kind of ugly ass watch
look up a set an eight early 80s omega
constellation it's just asinine look and
the original constellations are so
cool-looking they have a pipe and I'll
and a cool like Observatory on the back
but they just got like two stylish
whereas Rolex the same with Harley is
like we are a style we don't need to
follow what's cool we got like you saw
they tried to do that with the deep sea
yeah and it no one wears them no one
like and I don't even know it's so it's
not a lot of times Rolexes failures or
what become collectible absolutely but
I'd I wonder what the deep sea because
it's just hard to wear unless you're a
really big dude it looks and the
bracelet was too narrow in comparison to
the head of the watch now a perfect
example of that is the rolex milgauss
milgauss was a watch made for people
that worked around high magnetic fields
x-rays and nerds that worked in nuclear
nuclear stuff and they were completely
just a blue-collar watch yeah and now
they're [ __ ] a hundred
with honeycomb die if you have an
original one they're very expensive yeah
now I want to get into this before we
get into what they've done do you
remember what got you into relics
because for me it was James Bond one
hundred percent I was a bond freak I
always loved bond and you know they
would always show his Rolex the first
person I ever noticed having a Rolex was
a design teacher I had an art school
named Bruce Claypool up there in
pasadena other in passing and bruce
klappa was a really hard teacher and but
he was a nice dude and he had a Porsche
wow he had a sub any I the only thing I
knew about his career as he designed he
redesigned the Cincinnati Bengals using
uniforms but he was a really hardcore
teacher he had a sub and it just the
thing about it subs is the bracelets
perfect the the rolex oyster bracelet is
perfect looking yes flat it's shiny it
hits the light the way light hits is
perfect and the same thing with the
Rolex bezel it has these little scallop
cuts in the side of it so you can grab
hold of Internet and the way light hits
it is great and I remember just looking
at me like that watch is cool [ __ ] and
this is like the late 90s so I member
being like a [ __ ] that watch casa
thousand dollars yeah and then I kind of
looked him up and they were like two or
three thousand dollars which to me was a
million dollars totally so I was just
like oh that's a watch you get when you
have a lot of money you know and then
from there I think the next time I saw a
sub on something that I thought was cool
was like was a XO after that I knows him
was a Paul Newman and All the
President's Men he wears a 70s 1680 and
you know that's a a fantastic movie and
he just looks cool with that watch on
yeah and it's like he was like it wasn't
like hey I'm this flashy dude it was
just like this is a durable a swatch
yeah it's you know the black bezels for
diving you just like oh it's durable
yeah and then I started to notice it as
we've talked about this the sub is the
dirtbag watch it is it's it's a watch
that a dirtbag who's made a little money
buys you're like a successful mechanic
tattoo artist every time skateboarder
surfer about chopper bill yeah bike
builder all that those kind of dudes art
it like successful
artists when they get a little money
they're like hey I'm [ __ ] doing all
right over here yeah I'm gonna go buy a
Rolex and that's the one they've seen
and that's so when they buy so when I
look at those I don't think like rich
dude part of me thinks like guy who
maybe never planned on having [ __ ] in
his life was like holy [ __ ] I'm doing
okay it makes you feel good too yeah a
little bit and what people understand is
the rich guys they don't even wear relax
not really too [ __ ] entry level yeah
they clown him yeah my second real
introduction to Rolex and this really
made me [ __ ] love them was the deer
hunter okay there's the scene where
there with the revolvers and they've got
the GMTs up on the table and he's like
dang God dang God yeah I'm that guy got
and they've got their GMTs up there and
they're gambling like who's gonna blow
their head off first and that's when I
realized whoa military guys wore GMTs
back in the day Chuck Yeager war gmt to
break the sound barrier yeah they were
one of the watches tested to go to space
it didn't pass the speedmaster did Wow
but yeah the GMTs and they were also
GMTs were also the like official watch
of all the Pan Am pilots yeah the Pepsi
bezel one so those are always been
coolish i love a gmt i do too selling
that gmt was stupid yeah you can buy it
back he wants to sell it okay cool i may
get i made it but you know what though
dumber though is selling that [ __ ]
speedmaster would i get 2,800 you saw it
on HQ milton the most reasonably priced
site on the internet for 6,200 bucks
haha i got [ __ ] shafted on you know
what though when you sold it that's what
they were going yes so weird yeah that's
a good thing to tell you guys when you
buy a Rolex don't think you're gonna
make money i know a lot of people to go
I'm not by this man it's gonna be worth
money but if you wear a Rolex and let's
say you buy it for 5 grand 10 years from
now you could sell it for 5 grand all
the day long and probably way more a
lemur don't think about it as way if you
can keep I mean if I have no patience
for watches neither do you
want a new one all the time but I have
made money on watches if I had them at
least four years now the problem is the
market can change like right now for
some reason 90 subs are cheaper than
they used to be a 90 sub 8 months ago
with six grand but the markets been
flooded by them because I think the
brand new Rolexes have been out like the
new subs have been out now for long
enough to where you can buy a maybe
three year old sub for around six ish
yep so a if you can get a one that's
three years old versus one that's 12
years old for around the same price
maybe 500 more you're going to get the
new one yeah so that is pushed the price
of the 90s ones down so you can get a
sub again for five the subs basically a
five-thousand-dollar watch and five to
six grand and I think it will be for a
long time no matter what the retail is
on them even though now the retail is up
to like 7d whatever it's like 7,500
bucks 8 grand it's still there makes so
many of them but if you wait a little
while and get one on what's known as you
know the gray market get one pre-owned
you're going to save quite a bit of
money if you want to buy it spend that
much money i watch now if you're going
to buy used it's always going to be
crazy better deal on one that's a couple
years old but one of my point uh
pointers to you and your if you're a new
watch buyer and you don't know as you
wear these watches they they're
stainless steel they collect scratches
and everything and I like them looking
like that yeah but these guys can polish
these watches to where you walk into
store and they look brand [ __ ] new
you've got to watch out for that try to
get a watch unpolished which I didn't
know early on now because these guys
polish them and most of them are Ricky
polishers yeah and they they they
polished the bevels off the [ __ ]
links yeah and the and the watch starts
to look rounded yeah you want to it when
buying in a used watch from any decade
especially a Rolex the thing you want to
make sure it has is the original dial in
the original hands and it's if it's
unpolished perfect or if it's just been
lightly polished you want original
bracelet because all that stuff I once
bought a
a rolex submariner 1680 and it was a
reasonably price a little lower than
other ones I'd seen and I was like I
bought it from a store I was like how
why I wonder why this one's cheaper the
reason was it had a replacement dial
replacement out from Rolex what that
means someone but while owning it sent
it in to get serviced and rolex doesn't
give a [ __ ] about this stuff so they put
a new dial on it that glows because
people like that well on the bottom of
the doubt says Swiss instead of t25
which is a huge difference in the value
of the watch so what did I have to do
had tracked down a new goddamn dial cost
me 500 bucks which is the same price
that would have been if I'd have just
bought the one next to it which was the
same [ __ ] and this these are things you
don't even know when you first start out
no everyone I know has made a mistake on
a lot yeah you walk in you go oh yeah
that looks good and also I want to make
a big big point that if you do buy a new
Rolex which i always recommend buy new
from from a raw authorized dealer if you
do buy a Rolex they and you get it
serviced which they say they moved it up
to every five years now so 770 yeah
seven years so if you do oh yeah its
five-year warranty now seven years
service yeah when you get it serviced
and you're not anal / scratches you must
tell Rolex do not change anything on
this yeah dial the hands yeah I don't
want it polished or anything because
what they're doing is they're just tuned
in your watch up to make it look really
good for you what's it and a lot of
times there's stories of the old days
where Rolex right look at this rare dial
yeah they would switch out the dial and
go here we gave you the new dial so it
glows and you just lost a
ten-thousand-dollar dial yeah yeah so
you got to really put in the notes do
not touch this watch at all because the
genius of vintage Rolex is is the patina
if you see a totally mint looking new
old one that's just been refurbished
there's nothing cool about that you're
like oh gross yeah but if it's all
patina'd up and crazy looking that's the
step to me is the that's the crux of
what makes them worthwhile is the
movements are well made enough and
structure the case and the bracelet of
these watches were well made enough to
where you can see even in when they're
super old they still work so the dial is
super [ __ ] up and like crusty in the
Flitz flaky pie during yes spiderweb
cracking and stuff but the watch still
keeps great time and that's what's cool
and it's it's I could tells a story yeah
people go it's been here watching uh oh
this watch yeah it was on the set of
deer hunter yeah I got right now I'm
wearing an Omega Seamaster from 1962 the
thing keep it loses I timed it it loses
one second a day it's from its 60 years
old it's insane yeah and it looks great
and you know it keeps great time cost me
a thousand dollars big deal now before
we get into the Rolexes one other way to
get into great watches is a brand called
tutor tutor is the it's made by rolex it
was originally designed for the i
believe the british military and it was
kind of their more blue collar watch
line yeah and there they look a lot like
Rolexes almost exact almost exact in
design but they're specifically cool to
watch nerds because they were like the
dirty cousin yeah of rolex yep and today
we're called tutor but they had a Rolex
movement yeah and and then then they
changed it to less expensive movements
which I think was the kind of the secret
to having them be cheaper but now in the
last like what three or four years yep
three years tutor has they started with
the first reissue watch they did that
was kind of inspired by their old models
was i believe the monte carlo yep they
did the monte carlo kind of tribute
model and then they put out what's
called the black bay which was a
complete game changer in the watch world
a real and and and and we truly believe
and i truly believe this that Rolex is
they experiment with the tutor brand
yeah and then they bring it over into
Rolex now so what they did was they put
out a model called the black Bay that
looked like one of their old tutors you
and it was a guilt dial with a red bezel
and a big crowd and the watch world went
crazy looks like a Rolex big crown and
it is [ __ ] epic smokin I honestly
think that the tutor black Bay
especially now with the new in-house
movement it is the best value in
wristwatches 100% especially if you got
it on ebay for about eight hundred
dollars cheaper yeah you're getting a
watch that is the one of the finest
watches out there for the money even
brand new I mean you're talking a new
Rolex Submariner retails now for what
seventy-five eighty 180 100 bucks yeah
which you know I believe then I believe
the black Bay retails for like what 30
36 36 hundred bucks the thing is tough
as nails it and they kind of thing is
what's cool about it is it has a rican
get a red bezel yeah the red bezel with
the guilt dial which is crazy looking my
favorite is the blue bezel with the
white dial that's got a matte dial and
then now they have a black dial with the
guilt and then this year they came out
with a bronze case one unbelievable
unbelievable look with the 369 it's got
369 da like an explorer dial or like a
mil sub 43 mill 43 millimeter so it's
big like kind of like a dive watch or a
pilot's watch and then they also came
out with the black babe black which he
liked it PVD coated steel yeah which is
really big in the aftermarket no one
really makes PVD except for panerai a
lot of people IWC does too yeah a lot of
people would PVD their row x which is
the dumbest move ever well you can't
Rolex won't service at any right but
also tutor put out a watch last year
that [ __ ] knocked me out the pella
goes to titanium it's titanium and a lot
of people don't like a heavy watch this
watch it weighs about an ounce yeah and
it's big it's big like a submariner it's
like a big dive sport watch but it's
light and it's got a blue dial in a blue
bezel that's insane look with the date
yeah now a lot of people Kevin and I
like deer I wear a watch more as a
bracelet now because of course we all
look at our phone and
yeah but the main thing I really want
from a a watch is a date nay but now you
know all the watches i love don't have
date yeah like Daytona the milgauss yeah
yeah yeah that's the thing i love an
explorer one but it's got no date I love
the milgauss it's got no date so part of
me I'm tending to gravitate towards more
more towards a sub or a gmt or HS
because you get the date and I don't
like I kinda I'm trying to look at my
phone less oh we should also mention
tutor came out with 36 millimeter blood
yeah so this thing is insane looking man
yeah if the dial is crazy yeah it's a
perfect watch size for a lady wrist or
my wrist yeah but dude this thing's so
good-looking it really is and and and
women the big big style for women in
Hollywood like actresses stuff like I
remember what's her name Olsen twins
used to love to rock a panoramic yeah
right panerai like uh Hollywood
actresses like to get like Sharon Stone
wears a sub and it looks so cool on her
what's the girl from Charlie's Angel
that was with Justin Timberlake uh-uh
but but but bang bang turned and an
she's tall she was in the mask yeah
anyway she wore a damn friend Ian
Cameron Diaz I remember deejaying a
party and she had a date own on white
face yeah and I was like that looks so
dope women wearing sport diving watches
is so cool women in in in in Rolexes
like a subs or GMTs that knocks me out
yeah well as you know that when I see
that I'm like hey girl yeah well you
know they're they're like outside the
box yeah they're just like I want a big
tough badass watch go [ __ ] yourself yeah
they're not going the dumb Kardashian
route if I'm gonna get a cartier yeah
and um did it like a Cartier watch this
tutor like if I saw lady wearing a black
bay oh I'd be like what the what is your
story ever real how are you like you're
into cool [ __ ] she would have to be a
guest on here yeah but also the cool
thing about the black Bay's it has
what's called snow the snow
flake hands yeah and the the hour hand
is cool triangle shape on it but I mean
there's not many watches okay I love the
blue dot the blue bezel one but there's
not many watches out there that put out
a watch with a guilt dial right and so
that's what that's the cool thing about
the black bays you get a the guilt dial
is live rose gold color type yeah which
not a lot of companies do that so it's
pretty rare to see it and the hands have
rose gold around them too if you don't
know what a guilt dial is it's what
rolex did in the 50s and early 60s it's
a dial that has like gold writing yes
the printing says some air no but it's
in gold type and those I mean a 60 gmt
will cost you about eight or nine Grand
a 60s guilt dal gmt will cost you about
15 grand yeah a guilt I'll submariner
5513 is again like 15 grand we're as a
normal 5513 is eight nine ten thousand
dollars it's just those tiny tiny
differences that make a difference and
the thing is it seems like a thing that
doesn't matter but when you wear a watch
you look at the dial all the time yeah
and it's those little things on dials
that are just like simple little
beautiful things that every time you
look at your watch or like then that is
a beautiful like when you see a milgauss
green crystal in the Sun yeah with the
orange lightning bolt hand yeah it's
it's like [ __ ] it's it's it is it's
porno it's yeah it's I mean it's the
reason sometimes I gravitate more
towards subs and GMTs is because the
bezel on a sub it has an asymmetrical
design so it has these little sub like
dial markers on the right-hand side yeah
and that to me is just it's a little
asymmetrical it looks a little cool
makes it look a little techy and I mean
the thing i love about both these brands
to turin rolex is there just durable ya
don't have to like i used to have a gold
a lange & sun which is one of my
favorite companies on the planet but i
was every time I wore it I was worried
about bumping it into anything because
gold dense so he's totally but like
these are watches you can wear every
single day and the great thing about
both of them is you can pop off the
bracelet put them on a strap and you can
wear them with suit you can wear them
with basic
anything yeah and they're just a lot of
the the thing about these watches isn't
about telling time with us it's designed
yeah it comes down to being into a
really good art or or incredible cars
it's all design and rolex has really
[ __ ] smashed it out of the park all
these years with this Submariner style
design yeah i mean if you'll notice when
you look at a submariner design you'll
see that you've seen it on every other
watch company because it got so popular
that every watch companies tried to kind
of copy i'll copy i'll i mean we've seen
it time and time again with other you
know ball came out with a watch that
looked just like milgauss and like copy
the gmt orange hand and these are things
that appeared in other companies maybe
in the past but rolex is really the one
that that popularized it so a lot of
companies like you know you'll see a
seamaster and i'll look a lot like a sub
absolutely like the new the new James
Bond seamaster looks a lot like a big
crown sup it's sweet looking it is but
it and the sick in the 60s the sea
masters did kind of look like that Rolex
and and Omega were really neck-and-neck
back then battlin at one point Oh Matt
Omega was considered better than Rolex
but they both they both made exquisite
watches and that's why anything from
those two companies pre-1970 or 80 is
good yeah you know okay so let's get
into the Bowser world here so they
released these watches I'm up we were
not invited yeah we invite only did is
it yeah I don't think you can just go I
think you have to like they don't let
the general I mean first of all you're
talking about probably a half a billion
dollars in merchandise on the floor I
don't think you can go I think you have
to be invited well what's really crazy
about baza world and if you if you
hashtag baselworld 2016 on Instagram
what happens outside of as a world at
nighttime is even more crazier because
all these super gazillionaire watch
collectors show up and they have parties
like around poo
goals and stuff where they'll bring like
50 watches each guy yeah and you sit
around they smoke cigars and they'll
have watches that are worth almost a
million dollar sitting there yeah they
have these like passion events were a
bunch of really serious collectors will
meet in some crazy hotel and Europe and
they slay them all every time I look at
those pictures like how does everyone
know which is which it's crazy right I
mean you'll be looking at like 20
million dollars on a table worth of
watches it is insane to me but honestly
to me at that point it doesn't seem that
[ __ ] yeah it's too much writing maybe
although let's let's be honest we're
talking about guys that are probably
financial guys they're millionaires
we're talking multi multi-millionaire
yep so to them this is their fun it's
all ego too yeah it's like yeah look
what I got well that's the thing getting
some of these watches it's like I tell
people they laugh especially with the
company like Patek Philippe Patek
Phillipe which I was incredibly
disappointed with their releases at
battle this year design-wise something's
happened after that the head of the
company was a guy whose last name was
theory and he left and something has
happened to the design they don't feel
it's classic they feel like they're all
laid out on a computer I don't know what
it is they just the design isn't as warm
it doesn't feel there's no sense of like
hand done anything they used to have
really beautiful fonts up there's
something lacking in them I lost an arai
like 45 years straight this year they
release some great watches I showed him
day I was like oh my god yeah [ __ ]
they're back but panerai which by the
way has really crashed in value a lot
like not as bad as Frank Muller did yeah
but they've really gone down panerai was
really hot for a while and the big watch
is gone as far as style but panerai was
putting out this stuff you're like what
we're not [ __ ] Popeye the sailorman
like no one needs a Time Lord seven
millimeter watch yeah 52 millimeter Pat
X last big chronograph release which it
looked like it looked just like the
victorinox chronograph that you buy in
any watch during them all cuz that's an
okay watch whatever 300 bucks it'll last
a long time but a [ __ ] chronograph
patek philippe is like a hundred grand
yeah and I just I don't know what that
their releases left me very cold but the
thing is that what I'm saying is if you
even have the money to buy that watch I
can't get it yeah because I they make so
few those watches are already going to
people that buy tons and tons of watches
for my Ferrari yeah you can't just go
get the hybrid Ferrari you have to own
the 458 you have to know in the
California they make you on at least
three Ferraris before yeah now Pat tech
doesn't make you do that but they know
the shortlist of super collect well they
release a very small number of watches
to these stores and the stores are going
to give those watches to people that
spend a lot of my in their stores it
makes sense and it was like that with
Daytona's in rolex for long time right
you couldn't go by you couldn't go into
a Rolex authorized dealer and get a
black dial Daytona you still can you
still can't you still can't walk in
because they have created this
incredible phony market of their crazy
rare yeah and every dealer has nine of
them in the background I tell you what I
wish I wish I could get like an
ex-employee on here that could tell you
how that started because that watch
wasn't really that hot because in the
90s they were in the stores yeah all of
a sudden one day I was like you know
what I want to get a Daytona and they go
there's a two-year waiting list you go
what what for it's a stainless steel
yeah but if you wanted a gold Daytona
they had 90 in the case yeah they
created some which good hats off to them
it created this mysterious market of
there are not especially the black tile
ones yeah especially the black black
tile stainless steel was like if you you
can either buy used one but literally
you couldn't get when I walked in to
Geary's in Beverly Hills and I was like
gotten Daytona's they're like yeah I go
you got any black down the guy the guy
goes well yeah but I mean not for you
and like that it wasn't even that reals
like yeah man I know I was curious yeah
like you know he's like we set him aside
for guys that spend a hundred grand a
year in here yeah and they used to be
you couldn't buy they were above retail
that was a watch that was above Rhea
specially in the 90s it was more
collectible to get the one with the
zenith movement yeah well eventually did
make their own movement on only this
watch for ya so they had a Zenith
chronograph
forever and then once they switch to an
in-house movement the zenith one's got
more collectible but now you can I don't
think you can you could probably get a
black bow one down let me tell you how
it works now so you go into the rolex
store and you go looking for a Daytona
and they go oh man like a year list and
you go oh okay well cool just put me on
that way yeah and then hang out for
about a half hour all sudden the guy
will come out I swear to god this has
happened to me twice and he goes hey man
I went back and put your name on the
list there's one back there and that
we've been calling the next guy and the
look I didn't buy it yeah he's just you
know we could sell it to you today
instantly they've had one this has
happened to me numerous times or if you
really wanted one and they were they're
hard to get if you just bought them low
in robeks all of a sudden they could
sell you the other one too yeah I mean
the same thing happened with the blue
and black gmt which came out what two
years ago yeah the the bruiser like all
the bruiser of the Batman it was
instantly hot retail for 8950 they were
going for as high as like what 10 12 it
was crazy at one point where on
Christmas there 12 grams yeah so I go
into Nick muhindi jewelers in glendale
galleria and i go i go i'm thinking of
getting a gmt the regular one he goes oh
cool ok i'm looking at i go you got any
of the Batman's and he goes will I got
one I can oh but I could sell it to you
today but only today and I was like
really only today what's gonna happen at
the end of today and I was like how much
he's like retail I was like yeah I know
you know why because now everyone has i
watch yeah and now they're going for
just slightly under retail there was a
time when they put out the milgauss
which is a watch that they put a green
crystal on yeah and I believe it came
out in 07 yes it is impossible to get
because possible apparently the
technology of the green crystal was a
huge pain in the ass yeah and they kept
kind of having trouble with it was soft
or something yeah so they were always
delayed so you couldn't get him and
watch collectors were flipping the [ __ ]
out over the wad sold for at the time
6500 yeah
to get 120 grand yeah like and I would
remember being an aspen i was going to
Sturgis and I stopped in their rolex
store there and the guy goes we got 14
18 that's correct and people bottom and
then a year later they figured out how
to make the green crystal and they're
everywhere I mean [ __ ] everywhere and
those guys about them for 18 are just
[ __ ] the hand cuz you can get a good
used one for six grand now mitt yeah
yeah and it's a super cool watch I had
the milgauss without the green crystal I
think it cost me six i sold it for 5,500
yep I mean our buddy court McAllen wears
one he won that he won that in a golf
tournament or something that's actually
the non green crystal milgauss now oh
yeah is a really good value yeah because
you can get those i saw one as low as
4,500 bucks the white Dale one is like
40 200 bucks but it is ugly oh yeah but
not when you put the green crystal on it
yeah but yeah you can get a black dial a
normal black dial milgauss for like 45
hundred bucks if you want and that's a
phenomenal watch yeah it's a great
movement and again it's got the sweet
lightning bolt hand yeah I mean if
you're a rocker like me it's the watch
that makes sense yeah it looks like no
one's wearing it it's the AC DC yet
there is something cool about wearing
cuz Rolex especially in la if you go to
certain neighborhoods you see a million
of them million so it doesn't
necessarily feel special to wear one I
wear one I've liked wearing them when
I'm haddam because I'm now I'm old but
like when I was young and in my 20s I
always look a little young for my age so
I looked a little bit like a young poor
dirtbag yeah so it was sort of cool to
me to have a fancy watch so when I was
like go to meetings or auditions it was
like hey [ __ ] you guys yeah a guy said
it wants to me goes I can't you know I
wear a nice watch like a white girl I
can't drive my nice car into a meeting
yeah like yeah fair enough successful to
me it was about like contrast it's like
I you know I dressed like a skater and
they don't filthy [ __ ] clothes or
whatever with a salsa stain on him it
was kind of funny to me to have a nice
watch well I think it's the best look
like when you see a guy who's skate in
the pool
yeah you know anything he's got like I
mean you know just [ __ ] a dog town
some rector [ __ ] back in the day but he
had a sub on your like what no that [ __ ]
school and it's like hey man I got
successful doing something cool what did
you do get a job nerd ah so even and
even as I get older because of what I do
for a living when I do get lucky and
make a little extra money yeah it's I
like buying oh nice watch and you know
I've talked about this it's parachutes
that's it because if you say okay a
Rolex cost let's say five thousand bucks
right if I put five thousand bucks in
the bank I'm not buying like a mutual
fund I'm not smart enough now it would
it be smart to do that totally yeah will
I ever do it probably not so if I just
put 5,000 the bank well I'm gonna
Whittle it away you will taking the girl
to dinner buying sneakers hands yes
skate t-shirts maybe a skate deck I
don't see either at 2200 all of a sudden
it's gone yeah so buying like in this
just recently you know that I that my
dog had a thing and it looked at some
liver disease and my dog I have two dogs
they're my best friends and it wasn't
even a question of whether or not I was
going to pay for this [ __ ] so it ended
up costing 6,500 bucks which I handed
over the money gladly absolutely so I
sold the watch rope I sold a watch and
some art and those were just things that
I'd bought along the way of that any
time I got a little extra money I wanted
to get something cool with it I bought
stuff and like I sold a piece of art
that cost me 1,200 bucks and I got five
grand and then I I sold I bought that
date just for two grand you sold it for
2,300 yep and it wasn't about like the
Prophet necessarily but it was just like
I got the money back yeah exactly that's
what I tell people over and over we're
lunatics and we have no ah like I mean
we're smart but we're dumb also you know
what I mean somebody recently said hey I
heard it Harley you have bought in the
most motorcycles ever at Harley and I
said yeah well I heard that is true from
the Harley finance people
yeah you know cuz I bottom and flipped
him and turned him over and everything
and if you look at all the time and the
money that that was in I probably was
rich at many times in my life didn't
even know yeah from doing that from
flipping and [ __ ] but I would have been
bored as [ __ ] just sitting around like
all right I've got money in the bank you
need dinger to I think push you and do
what you what you want to do in the
corner yeah I think you just have to I
don't know I want to enjoy life as much
as I can and because I there have been
times in my life where I've made a lot
of money in a short amount of time
because I got lucky and got some job
that paid a lot or whatever TV yet
obviously TV get when they paid yeah
like a commercial the most one ever made
from a commercial campaign and they paid
me a lot of money in a short amount of
time now did I like having that money
yeah I wasn't happier necessarily nope
but I just I felt a little safer so but
I realized that having tons of having
extra money doesn't necessarily make me
happy I need enough so that I feel safe
and then I like stuff I love I me not
being an artist and having gone to art
school and stuff and making art all the
time I like I'm inspired by looking at
things and looking at things that I
think are beautiful are well made or
well designed and that's the stuff that
makes me like gets me excited cuz it
makes me want to do stuff makes me want
to make stuff makes me want to like you
know and even stand up wise yeah there's
something cool about like oh man i'm
going to buy this ironheart flannel or
these ironheart jeans or whatever like
these little cool on stage yeah or like
this watch a look cool on stage or like
whatever it is these glasses so like the
stuff I'm into in the stuff I buy a lot
of its I just like being surrounded by
things i find visually inspiring and
also quality yeah and in a lot of times
handmade yeah and most important in this
world of entertainment looking different
than the nine dudes that went on before
you and after you yeah I mean especially
the way I look every I look like a lot
of comedians oh I saw a guy
sunday at the Neil show and thought he
was you yeah so you know it's funny yet
for me to stand out if you go to any
comedy show in la you're gonna see three
dudes on a lamp look just like me except
they're gonna be wearing hoodies yeah
I'm garbage pants and shoes and are they
cool yeah so I'm like look I and at this
point also I'm a little spoiled yeah to
where I've owned a few things that are
really well made and it ruins me for
buying cheap [ __ ] totally like at the
eye last year got a job and I kind was
like I'm gonna go buy a nice flannel so
i bought the purple ironheart western
flannel [ __ ] not cheap nope but that
[ __ ] thing is like a suit of armor
I've worn it more than I've worn
anything it's still in perfect shape I
wore to Europe in the winter it's all i
needed i was just in New York it's 30
degrees that's all I needed and that
thing is so durable and well made I
don't ever buy normal like flannel
shirts from the mall because I just feel
like [ __ ] they don't fit right so they
don't fit yeah they're in a wool instead
of cotton to the edge so a flannel from
a normal stores 50 bucks well I in any
given year I probably what about too
well in the five years at least I'll own
this flannel I would have spent what it
costs on bad ones during that time yeah
hang with a closet you don't ever wear
them again and also with once again you
get in a little trouble that thing goes
on ebay you get to fifty-four cuz i
already made like a hundred yeah exactly
and that man that thing is good oh god I
got the same one dude it's better than
I've got the blue one and it's funny
last night is wearing the blue one and
I'm obsessed with leather jackets and I
don't and I I mean obsessed with leather
but when I put on the flan and I go this
is really all i want like to where i can
move in it yeah it looks great it fits
great makes you seem a little like when
i wear mine i'm a little less fat in it
okay yeah there's good cut it's thick
yeah so it holds it in a little bit haha
like I hate I hate a soft tee shirts cuz
they show off your boobs oh my god it's
so wrong I I had one and a guy took a
picture of me in the main room and it
was titty city dude again oh my god give
me a thick Hanes beefy tea please
you got dude I look so bad not trying to
wear an x-ray knock it off well I like
to wear the thin shirt underneath the
flannel yeah yes captain I yeah but yeah
gross yeah okay so let's get into the
Rolex releases and then we'll cut out so
Rolex this year released when I would
call a lot of people call their their
dream watch their Grail watch yeah this
watch that came out two days ago is
absolutely the delray Grail watch it's
fire it is the best looking watch they
put out in I don't know to probably it's
at least a decade me yeah absolutely
it's the Daytona and instead of the
stick it stainless steel which they
never [ __ ] updated like we said since
the 90s or whatever yeah they put a
ceramic bezel black on it yeah and they
gave you the white face with the black
sub-dials which is straight up the Panda
they only really changed the neck
because they didn't make the sub dial
solid black it's got a black ring and
then the bezels black so it's still the
same case yeah and movement and dial of
the old Daytona they just changed the
bezel color but it looks like the 70s
Daytona I believe the number is a 62 63
or 65 65 and it's it reminds you of that
style well the white one right now
stainless steel the sub dials are silver
yeah so this is black so you immediately
get the Panda look with the Red Riding
yeah and then um it's just very few
Rolexes have read type yeah right yeah
they got the yachtmaster yachtmaster the
this and well the Explorer doesn't have
a red type but it has a red hand right
so this watch they dropped it and
immediately I went to the Rolex form
people flipped out the website almost
crashed yeah I mean out all I saw on the
guys I fall on Instagram we're just the
word finally like dudes have been
wanting this to happen for a decade at
least yeah
they just been like please just put a
black bezel on it I and and what we're
saying is I really feel that Rolex with
with with social media now yeah they
cannot hide anymore from people's
feelings I think back in the day a guy
would be in his basement and he would
write a letter what the hell are you
guys doing or an email yeah but now with
Instagram and in Photoshop and Twitter
people are making the watch is on
Photoshop that they want to see and you
can see there'll be two thousand twenty
thousand likes whatever yeah and they
and eventually you cannot ignore money
on the table yeah yeah this watch is
going to be huge for them huge because
every if your butt and they didn't raise
the price really know so every guy who
wants to buy Daytona wants this one now
yep so that's any and guys who probably
didn't want a Daytona before or we're
going to buy a pre-owned one because you
can find a pre-owned what's the retail
on this now this one's going to be there
saying 13-8 out the door 13 grand 800
you can find more you can find a used
daytona between the years of 1995 and
2015 4 10,500 all day long and they're
mint with box of yeah there's brand
[ __ ] name yeah so for not that for an
if here's thing if you're in the market
for watches $10,000 you have a lot of
goddamn money or your Dean you're gonna
leverage your entire life you got your
trades and [ __ ] yeah so you probably you
have a lot of money so you once i know
it sounds like would you talking about
10 de who gives book but here's the
thing if you've decided to spend ten
thousand dollars on launched three extra
grand yeah to get this new one isn't
going to change your life and you're
probably going to do it all so let me
give you a couple of serious upgrades
what rollex did over the last few years
they made their own their own in-house
moving house movement for the daytona
and they upgraded the loom to this blue
loom yeah that [ __ ] glows
for a solid 24 hours where the old loom
a lot of times doesn't even work anymore
and if it does it works for about six
minutes and it's green and it goes away
yes Lulu Ms Krazie the new moon and then
the new easylink your wrist changes
throughout the day the size yet swells
so they've got this thing where it
changes by a quarter of an inch or
whatever instantly yeah and so all these
upgrades on the last five years of rolex
but a lot of that scum from tutor yeah
because tutor the Pella goes yeah came
out and had this spring adjustable
bracelet it's incredible which is
insanity so good because then you don't
have to be adjusting it it'll touch it
yeah you don't have to scratch it up I
take his like I address my watch all
time taking our Swiss Army knife I'm
popping things in and out you scratch
the bezel or scratch the lugs or
whatever and it's these it's these
little advancements just make them
easier to where it's what I mean you and
I talked about this a lot the more and
more I as time goes on I just want to go
buy a new one like I just want to buy a
new tutor and a new Rolex and I'm done
that's it then you go to it you know I'd
go to like an authorized dealer and then
there's no worries of who had this was
it stolen is it real and the it while it
is more expensive the peace of mind and
what you get now with peace among the
five year warranty seven-year service
thing it for the extra money I think
it's not it's negligible it's not that
big a difference if you're gonna if it's
gonna save you more than 2,000 bucks
that may be a thing right like for what
we've talked about I may be thinking
about getting the difference is like 2
grand yep but like what you get with
these new ones so badass oh my god it's
so great and there's even now there's
more models like dude the air king to me
was always too small the old model was
34 millimeters yeah it was like it
usually is it's the cheapest used rolex
you can buy you can find air king for
1,800 bucks and if you're a girl that's
the perfect size for females wrist looks
kick-ass yeah and they're inexpensive
but so I always liked them and I like
the fact that it's an air king I thought
there was a cool name but they were too
small for me so but now the new one what
is it 41 millimeters it
they brought the air king back in case
people didn't know it's part of the
sport it's basically there a sport model
yeah it's crazy the air king let me get
the size real quick it's 40 or it's
either it's either 39 40 or 41
millimeters which is the same size as a
milk out it's got a green hand and green
riding yeah it's just and then it has
these numbers on the dial pad which
which is really [ __ ] outside the box
for its 40 millimeter ok outside the box
for rolex this is unheard of this dial
that they made oh it's got a green hand
green hand green out of the yellow crown
yeah it's straight up the Shamrock imeem
this thing looks like a super simple
utilitarian stainless steel badass watch
thing looks tough as hell Oh Gyles great
I mean it looks like it's what the
Explorer one should have been when they
change the size it really is a home run
it kind of looks like a school clock
yeah like when you're in school it looks
like a Porsche pedometer and and I you
know I [ __ ] up by not getting the
price of this watch I wanted to know for
you guys because I don't think it's
going to be that much last year they
released those Perpetual's or whatever
and what were those 55 no yeah I think
they were 5800 right here's the deal you
guys that's okay retail this watch is
going to be successful but not like
crazy popular and in demand right so as
soon as this thing comes out about six
months later if it's this if say it's
5800 six grand you're gonna be able to
buy it on the grey market for from a
reasonably referee yep five grand 5,500
it's like the Explorer one when they
redid it it retailed for seven well
they're 5 grand all day yep oh god you
can get you can get one from the 90s for
3,500 yeah but that's the smaller size
right okay they redid the Explorer 12
fixed it they fixed it a few years ago
explore one was thirty six millimeters
the entire history of the Explorer and
in the 90s I bought an explorer one for
three thousand dollars
yeah in the 90s I bought it on time at
bainbridge they let you pay like yeah is
like [ __ ] forty dollars a month for
years with no interest you gold explorer
one was a watch that guys like to get
because it was like didn't feel as
feminist a chest and was smaller than a
sub and it was just like a cool sort of
masculine watch that wasn't huge and let
me tell you what happened and they're
really reasonable price there was
there's a japanese band called X there
in Japan not the X in the states right
and there's a famous guitar player in
that band and he bought the Explorer one
when when they redid it like 92 or
whatever came whenever it came out again
right you know this newer the 36 you
know sorry they put just the only
difference they put metal surrounds
around the markers they he wore it on TV
and it made this watch go through the
roof so I got it for three i sold it for
five well for a while you couldn't get
one they made it like the the Daytona
yeah like well we you're the waiting
list for that yeah you'd see him for 42
sometimes for a long time now they're
back to 36 right but they remade it like
what five years ago I think it was like
three years ago they put it was thirty
nine millimeter case which is a [ __ ]
great size perfect the old size of the
rolex submariner 5513 was thirty nine
millimeters it's a perfect size for me I
love it it's a great size watch but
there was something wrong with it yeah
you couldn't quite put your finger on it
but we were all fired up I was all dude
I was like this is right there it was
like oh I found it this is a perfect
watch I where the slim dead and then
you'd look at the dial you're like what
is wrong what is wrong about dial the
proportions felt off and it was because
the nut the the hands were too short
they used the old hands from the 36
millimeter models yeah on a thirty nine
millimeter dial so it just looked odd
and the the hour hand looked stubby and
short and then the the the numeric
markers the 93 and six were too big yeah
and they were felt like they were too
far apart it looked like a fake yeah it
looked fake and it looked a little fat
and oblong it didn't look sleek at all
and it's known as the stubby now yeah
which is hilarious because it'll be
worth money problems yeah probably
so now what they did was they made the
hands bigger and they just and I'm not
positive they even changed the they
didn't change the numbers but now they
glow they glow they've made them it's
unbelievable the numbers never glowed so
for years well the old printer ones
globe but they weren't nothing else
around but the last reissues you'd look
at your watch and it'd be glowing but
not the number so the 369 glow now and
besides the Daytona I think this is the
most epic watch that amount no simple
and classic looking in it the size of it
especially it for a man for may is a
perfect stainless steel walk and it's
not something that blows up when you're
walking out street they don't go Oh mr.
Rolex yeah but know what it is that's
why people I've noticed that is a lot of
the reason why the Explorer and the
Explorer one though I the Explorer one
is popular is because it's a Rolex that
doesn't like scream hey look at my role
is right and which by the way I want to
say something the Explorer to is now the
last steel bezel watch oh wow because
you know they you're right amicon this
unless they're going to still offer the
Daytona in the steel bezel which I don't
know why they would have Daytona
stainless steel with best steel bezel
and with we're a mimic ceramic vessel
right yeah they're not going to sell
bolt nut none of us know yet yeah I
wonder you got to see what's going to
actually hit the stores right so those
are our love's of this release all the
other releases are pretty much other
than they got a new date just 41 grade a
yacht masters prequel cradle yachtmaster
is legal and with the blue and it is
pretty much really that's another
outside the box watch for them yeah and
then they also did it in a rose gold and
stainless steel that dials crazy look
yeah right it really is crazy bronzy
brown color yeah so uh again if you
think we're crazy you're not wrong yeah
to spend this much money on a watch but
you know it's a specific hobby of taste
neither Dean and I have any
money yeah so we're not rich guys
talking about rich guys [ __ ] we save up
for the stuff yeah or you go to [ __ ]
banbridge and you get a lot they just
give you the watch and you just make
monthly payments payments it's crazy
yeah so you know uh again if Rolexes is
is you find annoyingly out of your price
range I cannot recommend to term or oh
god you know good and if you want to go
if you live in LA and you really want to
go see the tutors there's a great store
in Beverly Hills a tutor store and then
if you try watches on that's the gotta
try mon try mon and also don't freak out
about the weight or size at first
because after week you won't even notice
that stuff but again if you were if you
if you want to start out getting a nice
watch and not spend a ton vintage an old
rolex datejust man all day and if you're
looking for some used Rolexes it's a
course always scary on ebay and stuff
just go to the Watts rolex form there's
tons of guys on there that have huge
reviews and that you can trust or go to
a store that some of your friends might
have shopped at and i recommend i like
Philippe's and beverly hills and for new
Rolexes I like [ __ ] what's my place
calling in koreatown I don't know it's
cold god I forget the name right now
yeah that's stupid anyway there they
don't let you in anyways yeah I got
again you and the good luck shown up
there they wouldn't let into they would
let me they wouldn't let me in as
malaria secrets button but they are a
actual good store once you get in so
anyway thanks for tuning in to another
handmade episode and thanks keV for
doing it no my pleasure and we'll see
we'll be back again in 2017 thanks for
turning into let the bee talk
you